Ослаблення гривні, стрибок цін на товари та послуги,
зростання рівня безробіття, зменшення або відтік інвестицій.
Найгірші економічні сценарії для України
стали цілком реальними після рішення Конституційного суду,
який визнав неконституційною статтю
кримінального кодексу про покарання чиновників
за незаконне збагачення. І скасував ії.
- В нас можуть великі проблеми вже влітку
цього року з фінансовою стабільністю.
Імовірність дефолту - більш, ніж 50%.
У Центрі економічної стратегії не виключають, що
рішення Конституційного суду спровокує
негативну реакцію західних партнерів України,
адже кримінальне покарання за незаконне збагачення
було однією з вимог ЄС щодо безвізу і одним із
зобов’язань України перед МВФ. Напередодні
надання ЄС макрофінансової допомоги у розмірі 600 мільйонів євро
і рішення МВФ про виділення чергових траншів, яких
очікують у травні, це вкрай ризиковано, вважає Гліб Вишлінський.
- Якщо ми не отримаємо  грошей від МВФ у травні,
то в уряді будуть дуже великі проблеми
з проходженням цього року в частині виплат за зовнішнім боргом.
Воно цього року складають близько 7 мільярдів доларів.
Скасування статі про незаконне збагачення,
за висновками НАБУ, по суті є зміною
антикорупційного вектору України. Тут називають
рішення суду "політично вмотивованим і таким, що
протирічить зобов’язанням України
за ратифікованою Конвенцією ООН проти корупції".
Адже мільйонні статки, отримані з джерел,
законність яких не доведена, в Україні відтепер не вважаються карним злочином.
НАБУ заявляє, що тепер зведені нанівець
кількарічні зусилля детективів щодо розслідування
майже 70 справ щодо незаконного збагачення численних можновладців.
Ідеться про корупційні статки на щонайменше
півмільярда гривень. Усі ці справи НАБУ
буде змушене закрити і викинути на смітник.
Так само, але ще різкіше, висловлюються і в Центрі протидії корупції.
- Це рішення КСУ є нічим іншим, ніж
амністією для корупціонерів, які отримали
необґрунтовані активи після Революції Гідності,
саме за часи 2015-2019 років.
Це просто відбувається відкат назад.
Вони хочуть, щоб було так, як за Януковича.
Що просто неможливо сісти в тюрму за корупцію.
Справа Віктора Януковича - приклад ефективності
боротьби з корупцією по-українськи.
Більшість майна, статків, активів президента-втікача
досі де-юре належать його фірмам або фірмам наближених до нього людей.
За 5 років досі нікому не вдалося довести в суді, що
все це багатство є результатом злочинного збагачення.
Активісти вважають: за цією ж схемою діє і нова українська влада,
яка перед виборами вирішила перестрахуватися і
прибрати з законодавства інструменти можливих утисків
або переслідувань із боку нового президента і його команди.
Але формально в поданні 59 депутатів, які
звернулися до Конституційного суду, йшлося:
стаття про незаконне збачення порушує
презумпцію невинуватості та засади верховенства права.
Конституційний суд погодився з їхніми аргументами.
Мовляв, та стаття зобов’язувала підозрюваного
довести законність своїх статків. Це маніпуляція,
заявляють і НАБУ, і громадські активісти.
- Це неправда. За злочин “незаконне збагачення”
можна сісти тільки, якщо прокурор доведе
необґрунтованість доходів. Нема такого, що
прийшов прокурор, сказав до суду: от цей мені не подобається,
здається, що в нього забагато активів,
нехай доводить зворотнє. Ні, такого в українському кримінальному кодексі немає.
Цей пам’ятник громадські активісти встановлювали
з нагоди старту роботи НАЗК і започаткування
в Україні електронного декларування. Завдяки
відкритості реєстрів українці побачили реальні -
часом шокуючі - статки можновладців.
Антикорупціонери побоюються, що після
скасування статті про незаконне збагачення
влада може перейти якщо не до закриття, то
принаймні до згортання доступу до е-декларацій.
Президент Петро Порошенко намагається
заспокоїти суспільство і доручає внести
новий законопроект про відповідальність за незаконне збагачення.
Але за місяць до виборів сама ситуація, коли
незаконне збагачення раптом стає цілком законним,
перетворюється на карт-бланш для корупціонерів.
А з точки зору багатьох антикорупціонерів,
ця ситуація мало чим відрізняється
від останніх місяців керування країною Януковича і його друзів.